[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
today
i'm gonna teach you guys how to do rna
extraction
i'm gonna extract my knowledge of
rna and give it to you was that pun
cringey enough i don't i don't think it
was cringy enough it's got to be
cringy jokes for me it's not it's not
for you oh how about this
i'm gonna purify this
solution for you that was that was that
good
anyway all right we're gonna talk about
rna extraction we have different buffers
here we got the plates
so there's essentially two ways to do
rna extraction
there is the automated way and then
there's
going to be the manual way with the mag
plate we're going to go over both
so the first step is to prep the plates
for rna extraction so you got to load
all these solvents
into these well plates all right so now
we're going to talk about the materials
that we're going to need for
this analysis we're going to have your
sample tubes containing your samples
we have these are your tip combs
we have all the different 96 well plates
that we're going to use we have protein
ace k
we have magnetic beads we have a reagent
reservoir
and then you have your lysis buffer wash
one which is an isopropanol based wash
wash two which is an ethanol based wash
and then elution buffer which is water
and definitely of course you're going to
need some pipettes and pipette tips
and if you're doing things manually
you're going to also need a mag plate
all right so let's talk about the plates
over here in the first plate you're
going to have your
tip combs this is going to protect your
magnetic rods from contamination
so if you want to think about it it's
like contraceptive
for your magnetic rods this second plate
is going to be your lysis buffer
this is going to help bust up those
viral cells and cause them to release
the rna
this is going to have kind of a
guanidine based salt
might have phenol chloroform other
things you have your proteinase k
which denatures protein and of course
your magnetic beads
this is going to help bind the uh the
loose rna
the third plate is going to have an
isopropanol based wash
this is going to get rid of small debris
and this is going to
kind of be a first step in cleaning up
the beads and then
secondly we have a second wash which is
an ethanol based wash
it's going to further clean up the
sample get it nice and clean
and then the final step is your aleutian
buffer which is essentially just water
it's going to cause those beads to cough
up that rna so in the solution you have
lysis buffer you have your protein ace k
and then
you have your magnetic beads you're
going to pipet the lysis buffer in
with these components and then you're
going to add your sample and that's
going to sit for a while to let the
license buffer kind of do its job
after it does its job you want to kind
of pick up the magnetic beads with this
tip come so the tip comes going to come
over the machine is going to grab it
and it's going to come over boom and
then it's just going to like
mix it and then the beads are going to
stick there
so now that everything is lysed and
the magnetic beads with the rna is on
the tip comes now the tip comes is going
to go over to the first wash
so again it's going to pick it up and
this is a isopropanol based wash it's
going to pretty much
wash everything into solution that's not
beads and rna so it's going to pick it
up again
and it's going to go over and then it's
going to
[Music]
[Applause]
agitate it again and give it a good wash
okay finally for good measure
we're going to do one more wash with
ethanol
so again the magnetic rods are going to
be on the magnetic beads with the rna is
going to be over
and it's going to go over to the ethanol
and then
man like it's like it's just like for
minutes right and then you're just like
he's just like he's gonna do this for a
while and lastly
you know you have your magnetic beads
again on the rods
and it's illusion time right so you know
we're going to be like
give me that rna baby yeah you know give
it back you know
get them get them off the get them off
the beads and then
but then this time the magnetic beads
stay here
but the water that has the
the rna is here so this is like
trash now and this is the gold and you
know this goes
you know pcr time so if you're gonna do
this manually
you know you got no machine that didn't
know it's all good you can have a
magnetic plate here
then you're going to be able to put your
plates there
so instead of the magnetic beads moving
from station detection
the magnetic beads either go
if they're off the magnetic they're in
solution
and when they're on the mag plate
they're pelleted at the bottom
so off in solution on
pelleted at the bottom so essentially
all the steps are the same
but when it's time to move the magnetic
beads you're not moving them you just
have
one plate but for everything and what
you're doing is
you're pipetting out the liquid and
putting a new liquid
so for example if we're going to go from
the lysis buffer to the wash step
everything's washing here
nice and mixed you pellet it here
now that things are pelleted you're
going to pipet out
the lysis buffer and then you're gonna
pipet in
the wash and then you're gonna take it
off for mixing so the same concept
but one plate and you're just going back
and forth
thank you so much for watching that
video if you found the video to be
helpful
please like and subscribe and don't
forget to click that notification bell
we have similar videos here um feel free
to check them out
lastly if you have ideas for videos
please put them in the comments section
below
thanks